president trump is fighting in court to
win another four years
but if that doesn't work out for him he
is not losing hope and he doesn't want
you to lose hope
either it's been an amazing four years
we're trying to do another
[Applause]
otherwise he'll see us in four years the
show keeps going on i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday is from
haley who says if the founding fathers
were alive
they would have voted for trump
unfortunately they are dead
so they probably voted for biden this is
true that's something that the biden
campaign can brag about i'm sure every
single one of the founding fathers
did vote for him and they all moved to
pennsylvania actually
yes some of them were already there
that's where the constitutional
convention was
you know donald trump is not giving up
i i know there are so many questions is
the trump campaign going to win these
legal battles well they keep getting
shot down in court well is he going to
is it going to go to the supreme court
are they going to keep fighting for four
years there is
a lot of endurance that's being shown by
the trump campaign by the way if you
want to keep up your endurance you got
to check out
liquid iv liquid iv for when you're
out there you're athletic that doesn't
really happen to me
but if you also maybe stay out light and
have a few coca-colas with the boys
liquid iv is a great way to stay
hydrated you know cooler weather
makes it easier to miss signs of
dehydration such as
overheating or perspiration which means
that it's even more important to keep
your body properly hydrated with one
stick of liquid iv
in 16 ounces of water you will get two
to three times the amount of hydration
as plain water the other great thing
about liquid iv
is that it tastes excellent i was afraid
that it was going to taste like some
syrupy awful terrible concoction
it doesn't all the flavors i've tried
taste absolutely great
perfect for staying hydrated this
holiday season maybe you're going to be
on a
flight maybe you're going to be taking a
long trip maybe you're going to be
hitting the eggnog a little too hard who
knows maybe you're going to be playing
football with the family
in any case stay hydrated seriously
you'll feel much much better liquid
ivy's best-selling hydration multiplier
now has three flavors
watermelon delicious apple pie
even more delicious or my personal
favorite guava liquid iv
is available at walmart in the beverage
section or
you can save 25 right now if you go to
liquidive.com
and use code michael mich ael at
checkout
that is 25 off anything you order using
code michael
at liquid iv.com get better hydration
today at
liquidity.com promo code michael
m-i-c-h-a-e-l
president trump is pushing for
four more years he's going to duke this
thing out in court presumably until the
electors vote on december 14th
and then if it doesn't work out he'll
run again that's at least what he said
at the white house christmas party maybe
he is
just putting that out into the world
maybe he doesn't really mean it
maybe he's not really prepping a
campaign but this is the right attitude
i think right now there are
conservatives on both sides of this
question
who are missing the the right attitude
some conservatives are saying this is it
we're only going to fight for this
if we don't win this race then we're not
going to vote for senators then we're
not going to vote in four years then
we're gonna basically give up on the
political process that's one side the
other side says trump's gotta concede
now
if he doesn't concede to joe biden he's
destroying the norms of our constitution
if he follows the constitutional process
he'll be behaving in such an
unconstitutional way
and no both sides i think are wrong
there
we need to fight and we need to
acknowledge
realities and we need to remain
courageous we mean
we need to remain hopeful hope is a
theological virtue we need to
remain courageous that is the
prerequisite of all the other virtues
we can do all of those things at once
we we need to fight this as though
this is the battle because this is the
battle but we need to recognize
there are going to be other battles we
live in time we live in space if
president trump
is looking ahead at the future and
saying okay look i want to win this i
feel we did win this i feel there was a
lot of fraud i feel there was a lot of
cheating
but guess what buddy if you guys do
manage to win this at the level of the
courts
you're not going to keep me down i'm
going to keep running again that's the
right attitude some conservatives
are getting demoralized including some
of the most
vocal defenders of president trump sean
hannity on his
program the other day was speaking with
the lawyer sidney powell
and sean hannity suggested that if biden
becomes president
if donald trump is on his way out that
he should issue a pardon
for himself and for his family
i watched andrew weissman come out and
literally say oh
biden's a.g needs to go after donald
trump
and i'm like the president out the door
needs to pardon his whole family and
himself because
they want this witch hunt to go on in
perpetuity
they're so full of rage and insanity
against the president i mean it's
can can the president i i assume that
the power of the pardon
uh is absolute and that he should be
able to pardon anybody that he wants to
it is absolute it's in the constitution
i don't know about his authority to
pardon himself
but it should not be necessary and aside
from that the president's going to get
another four years in office to finish
the job he started
so sydney powell is still really holding
out hope we'll get in one second to
uh her legal strategy here you'll recall
that sydney powell is not working
officially with the trump legal campaign
well the trump campaign
is focusing on specific matters of
election fraud and unconstitutionality
in pennsylvania
sydney powell is pursuing this idea that
there was a national
very widespread hacking scheme
to shift votes so she's still pursuing
that but
to sean hannity's point seems to me
that's not the right attitude to have
due respect to sean
i get it it's true the biden legal team
is going to
try to go after trump they're going to
have a lot of
encouragement from the base to these
frothing jackals of the
democratic base to to go after trump
once he leaves office
but i don't think trump should pardon
himself because trump hasn't done
anything
illegal there would be nothing
to pardon himself for and you know i
think that's sort of hannity's point he
says whatever they go after trump for he
should just pardon himself now i don't
think that's how pardons work
we certainly haven't seen that sort of
thing in american history i think if
trump were to do anything of that sort
it would be giving in too much it would
be giving into despair and
discouragement
it would be giving into fear servile
fear by saying i think they're going to
come get me so i
exonerate myself of what i don't know
but whatever they accused me of i didn't
do it
and it would be in a way an admission of
guilt
guilt again for what i'm not quite so
sure
in america we do not have a political
tradition of jailing
our vanquished politicians at least at
the presidential level
and we don't have a tradition of jailing
our political opponents in this country
even though some of them probably do
deserve jail
for instance some people who were the
former future or first female president
four years ago
you know those sort of people there is
evidence that they've done things that
are illegal we still don't put them in
prison
because that's what tin pot
dictatorships do that's what banana
republics do and we don't want to do
that
if president trump were to pardon
himself as
sean is describing here it would be
a sort of concession that we're now
living in the world where we jail our
political opponents once they leave the
presidency
i don't think that's the right way to
play it i understand
why people are reacting with such
extremes to this legal process right now
either to saying the whole country is
completely over or to saying
that trump's got to give up immediately
or the country's over it's because we
don't like
tension i've noticed women especially
don't like tension they don't like
apprehension
but generally we all don't like
uncertainty and so we want to resolve
the uncertainty
even if it resolves in a way that is
unpleasant even if it resolves in a way
that would that we're fearing
even if it resolves to the point that
we're now saying we jail our political
opponents once they leave the presidency
but they just because we don't like the
apprehension we just want
some conclusion so we don't need to be
in suspense life
is lived in suspense you don't know
what's gonna happen
patience is a virtue and if you
if you keep up that sort of attitude
where you say okay you're gonna do your
worst to me
you're gonna completely vanquish me you
think you've vanquished me i don't think
so i'll see you in four years
that is a winning strategy that is
courage now you heard sydney powell on
that clip
mention that she is convinced that there
is this nationwide election fraud and
not just that there's nationwide
election fraud but that
they will prove this in court and
president trump will get another
four years in office which she's
describing a sort of confidence here
that i think even
president trump is not necessarily
displaying so what
is her evidence the election fraud we
are uncovering
is massive and there were foreign actors
involved
in our system people from germany and
serbia
and china were all in our election
the night it happened so i have no doubt
that foreign actors tried to interfere
in the election
i'm not sure exactly how they did it
this was by the way our response
in 2016 the left said that the russians
tried to interfere in the
presidential election and some
conservatives i guess deny that but i
don't deny that the russians tried to
interfere
foreign actors try to interfere in every
single election
the question is how successful were they
with the so-called russiagate
they bought a hundred thousand dollars
worth of facebook ads media companies
spend that in a week on facebook ads
that that doesn't that's nothing that's
not going to affect it
now cindy powell's claim is that these
foreign actors were actually going and
hacking the voting system shifting the
votes
again i have no doubt that they would do
it if they could i have no doubt
that they are that corrupt and they want
to
to mess up our system the question is
can you prove it and time is ticking you
know we have what less than 10 days now
until no about i guess about 10 days
until the electors
vote so how much longer before we
how much longer do we have to wait how
much longer we have to be in the
suspense and apprehension
to see this evidence of the hacking it's
not enough
to say i have a hunch that this happened
sure
it's not enough to say this could have
happened absolutely it could have
happened
you have to prove it with certain that's
just a descriptive
fact of our political and judicial
system you've got to prove it
with a high degree of persuasion and so
far we haven't seen that happen
so i hope that she brings the goods but
as of now we haven't seen it now there
is specific evidence of fraud
in in certain cases not even just at the
presidential level in one congressional
race in new york
involving a congressional candidate i
actually know personally
the two candidates the democratic
incumbent and the republican challenger
are separated by 12 votes
i want to talk about your vote mattering
want to talk about uh going out there
even if it's a system that's
vulnerable to fraud so new york's 22nd
congressional district you've got the
republican claudia tenney
has a 12-vote lead over the democratic
incumbent anthony brindesey and
that's good news right because that
means claudia is going to win the
republican's going to win we're all good
oh it's been it's been almost a month
now since
the elections i think we should be able
to count our ballots by now
we'll talk about a tin pot dictatorship
we can't even count our ballots within a
month
well no we have to keep counting the
ballots until the democrat wins claudia
has a 12
vote lead well guess what conveniently
they just found a batch of 55 ballots
they were hidden i don't know where they
were they were underneath the mail truck
or something
they just found this batch the
chenango county attorney alan gordon
said that election officials
determined that of these 55 ballots
found 44 of them are valid
now the other way to read that is 11 of
these votes
were fraudulent were ineligible
uh how'd they end up there so 44 are
valid
44 could swing an election easily if the
election
is right now hanging by 12 votes
so uh this county attorney
has advised the board of elections to
secure the ballots leave them unopened
in their offices
and obviously throw out the ones that
are illegitimate
but now 44 ballots i hope they're
unopened i hope that
their legitimate ballots i hope that
they weren't just being held
in case they were needed by the
democrats but when the votes trickle in
and trickle in and trickle in
until the democrats win that that does
not give us confidence in the system
it it discourages us in some way because
we feel like we can't win but they're
still fighting claudia tenney
is still fighting and there's a lot of
uncertainty right now
of course but do we want to just throw
up our hands or do we want to actually
try to secure
our future one way to secure your future
when there's a lot of uncertainty is to
invest in gold
now there's a there's a difficulty with
investing in gold i enjoy investing in
precious metals the trouble is
gold is expensive gold has been
skyrocketing i don't know if you've been
paying attention to that recently so
gold is expensive you can't usually just
go down to the local dime store and buy
a bar of gold
you probably don't have that cash lying
around well acre has figured out this
brilliant way to invest in gold you can
invest in gold bars
for just 30 a month but michael gold
costs more than 30
yes i know what you do you uh subscribe
it's 30 a month to acre and then once
your
stash has reached the amount of the gold
bar acre will discreetly ship you
the physical gold to your home so you
get actual physical gold
very important especially when times are
crazy especially when people
don't know that they can rely on on the
systems it's just a good hedge
against a lot of uncertainty i've always
enjoyed investing in precious metals
right now by the way acre just recently
introduced
their new hundred dollar per month
subscription for their five gram gold
bar
visit getacregold.com knowles k
w l e s start investing in physical gold
today
make sure you go to this url because
acre is giving away a gold bar that's a
good thing i'd like to win a gold bar
the way to qualify is to tweet or post
why you should be the recipient
and mention at get underscore acre that
is getakergold.com
knowles and thank you acre gold for
supporting the show
there is evidence of
shenanigans of irregularities but i
don't think we should just throw up our
hands you know some people
not president trump president trump is
saying go out keep up the fight
vote for the republicans in georgia make
sure we hold the georgia
senate seat so therefore we will hold
the senate majority
he's saying that there are some people
who are saying don't even vote in
georgia
don't justify don't legitimize this
fraudulent voting system i completely
sympathize with that point of view
i empathize with it i guess because it
feels as though
in many places where it counts the
system is rigged
conveniently a pipe bursts and oh we got
to stop counting
go home poll watchers at 10 30. oh hey
guys maybe you can keep counting now
that those republicans are gone
oh look it's going to the democrats in
pennsylvania oh gotta
sorry we're not allowed to have
republican poll watchers here in new
york with claudia's race oh look
claudia's winning well we just found
another batch of votes i get it
it's easy to just throw your hands up in
the air
that is not going to be
and if a winning strategy going forward
because we are still going to live here
and either we're going to have
well if joe biden does become president
either we're in a bad government
or if he becomes president with a
republican or a democratic senate
majority we're going to have really bad
government and if we just check out of
the process altogether we're gonna have
really really really bad government
so you've gotta you've gotta pick the
lesser of these two
bad situations uh ben is actually gonna
be talking about this on the show he's
gonna be talking about this
move to sort of throw up your hands and
not vote in georgia and why it's
important that we actually do vote
in georgia now there are other ways to
challenge the election
even beyond the electoral college voting
so the electoral college votes on
december 14th
then the congress is going uh have to
have the opportunity
to challenge that vote it's another
phase in the process and alabama
republican representative mo brooks
is telling his colleagues that he plans
to challenge the results
of the electoral college vote if the
body votes to certify
democratic presidential candidate joe
biden as the next president
now how does this work the electoral
college votes
then if a member of the house and a
member of the senate
uh raised this objection and challenged
the electoral college vote
this opens up the floor to debate
uh the the floor of the house and the
senate will have to deliberate on this
matter
okay fine that's a great last ditch
effort but if it comes to that
then that last ditch effort and a dollar
fifty will get you a cup of coffee
the house is in democratic control the
senate
i hope remains in republican control
we'll see in january
it would be a strong way to
basically scream against the wind but it
probably would not accomplish
very much and right now
we need to keep up the fight for the
presidency and for the senate
but we also have to look at
probabilities and realities
so that we can make the most of our time
right now this is something that bill
barr is doing so
we mentioned yesterday that bill barr
came out and said so far he hasn't seen
evidence
of widespread hacking sort of the fraud
that that sidney powell is talking about
he he since came out by the way and
tempered that statement he said i'm not
saying there's no fraud that went on i'm
not saying there's
i'm not even saying there's not enough
fraud to overturn the election i'm just
saying
we have not seen it yet bring it to me
you know bring it on please please
but in the meantime bill bar did
something behind the scenes i think is
very important
you've heard of the john durham
investigation this is a criminal
investigation
into the origins of the russia hoax and
into wrongdoing at the fbi and the doj
and the deep state the blob
right there's a big worry here that if
joe biden becomes president
there goes john durham there goes the
investigation we're not going to find
out
how the russia hoax started we're not
going to find out if joe biden was
involved in that because there's a lot
of evidence that he was
or that susan rice was involved in that
or the barack obama was involved in that
that they had direct knowledge so what
bill barr just did
and he did it surreptitiously is he made
john durham a special counsel you
remember special counsel it's the
the same procedure that created the
mueller investigation
the special counsel has much more
latitude
to conduct an investigation what this
means is that if joe biden
does become president he's not going to
be able to fire
john durham so easily so there's a
greater chance that we'll get some
results again i don't have
a great deal of faith we're always we're
always told
that these investigations are going to
uncover corruption and all these guys
are getting hold off to jail which
probably is not even a great idea anyway
but you do want them to face
consequences you do want them to to face
justice especially these lower level
guys john brennan
clapper these guys actually probably
should see an orange jumpsuit
and then it just doesn't turn out that
way then they they come up with nothing
when it's democrats alleging if they
come up with nothing even when it's
republicans
they come up with nothing but at the
very least this gives us a chance
we're in this state of of anticipation
we're in this state of not knowing okay
fine we've got to drag that out when
that is the best
option that we have we can also take an
important opportunity
right now to break up the left wing
educational cartel this is something
that betsy devos the education secretary
has been working on you're seeing this
go into overdrive
right now when there is chaos about
you need to set up some insurance
policies okay
and well one way to ensure your family's
safety by the way is
ready wise ready-wise a better time than
ever to be prepared with long-term
nutritional food options
ready wise has a ton of options
including emergency meals
freeze-dried fruits and vegetables for
convenient on-the-go nutrition
and new adventure meals for hiking
camping and other outdoor activities
ready wise taste great they make being
prepared simple and affordable you order
online you have nutritious meals shipped
directly to your doorstep
right now given everything that's going
on there is increased demand so supplies
are limited some items may currently be
out of stock
get prepared now when
trouble strikes that is not the time to
get prepared
that's definition of preparedness you
got to do it beforehand just do it now
it's peace of mind
you'll feel better you'll feel safe your
family will feel safe
don't put this off don't put yourself in
a situation where you need food during
an emergency and you don't have it
get ready today ready wise makes being
prepared simple and affordable
it's very very easy all you need is four
cups of water the water doesn't even
need to be hot
you then pour the food into the water
stir it cover it 15 minutes later the
meal is ready
some meals can even be prepared directly
in the pouch which eliminates the need
for additional supplies
this week my listeners can get free
shipping at readywise.com
when entering knowles can wles at
checkout or by calling 855-453-2945
readywise has a 90-day no questions
asked return policy
there is no risk taking the initiative
to get yourself
and your family prepared today that is
r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e.com promo code knowles
to get free shipping
right now amid all of the unfair things
going on the lockdown we're locking down
again aren't we and
the people who are locking down these
democratic governors and mayors
aren't abiding their own lockdown orders
gavin newsom is having michelin rated
meals at the french laundry
you have the l.a county supervisor
saying we need to shut down it's not
safe and then two hours later she goes
and has dinner
in santa monica it's very very
frustrating
but don't get demoralized there are
opportunities in crisis there are silver
linings even to storm clouds
betsy devos pointed out that
higher education lower education too
though right now amount
basically to socialist indoctrination
and that what the government is
attempting to do if there is a biden
administration is not just we're not
just talking about what is being taught
in schools
left-wing ideology but the the actual
move by the government
to install a socialized takeover
of the educational system policy should
never entice students into greater debt
nor should they put taxpayer dollars at
greater risk
there are too many politicians today who
support policy
that does both still more advance the
truly insidious notion of government
gift giving we've heard shrill calls to
cancel
to forgive to make it all free
any innocuous label out there can't
obfuscate what it really is
wrong the campaign for free college is a
matter of total government control
make no mistake it is a socialist
takeover of higher education
now depending on your personal politics
some of you might not find that notion
as scary as i do
but mark my words none of you would like
the way it will work
absolutely right i know that people
bandy about the word socialism and
sometimes they use it incorrectly
maybe often they use it incorrectly
betsy devos is not using it incorrectly
here
what the government is talking about the
government already has a role in
education
they're public schools and obviously
public state colleges
with what the government is talking
about now what the biden team is talking
about
is giving giving out free education
what does free education mean free
education means
that the government will control the
entire
higher education system and it might be
through a few layers so it might not
seem direct but
but he who pays the piper calls the tune
and if the government does get involved
in that that is
a full-on government takeover of
education that is a socialist
power grab what can we do now to prevent
that well we can keep fighting in court
hopefully we prevent the biden
administration
well we can keep fighting hopefully
prevent a democratic senate so that they
don't
they don't have the ability to pass this
kind of radical legislation they'll just
do it from the bureaucratic level but
they'll be more hampered that way
what else can we do we can we can vote
with our feet
all right suppose vote with our wallets
and
break up this educational cartel you are
seeing this right now i said it was the
silver lining of the lockdowns
that public school attendance is down
everybody's complaining about this the
students are falling behind
yeah that's true they might not be
learning their arithmetic although if
it's common core math then maybe it's
good they don't learn that
it also means they're not going to be
learning their radical left ideology it
also means they're not going to be
learning the 1619 project
that teaches them to hate their country
it also means that
you're going to see new educational
opportunities homeschooling
different pod learning communities
parochial schools growing private
schools charter schools
that's what we need to do we need to
take that up to the college level as
well
it i understand that people still feel
that going to college
is always 100 of the time the way to get
a good credential to get you a better
job
i think that is becoming less and less
true every day
i'm a defender of liberal education i
know there are a lot of conservatives
who say
don't worry about education you know if
you're gonna
go to school major in engineering or
something i'm not one of those guys i
think if you
go to school you should very likely
major in english or history
or philosophy i am a total defender of
liberal education
and the liberal arts but that's not what
you're getting at most of these colleges
and the price tag is way too hard to
justify it i don't think the point of
college
is to go out and get a job it's actually
the opposite it's to learn things that
are not
practically useful at all they're just
useful in helping you make sense of your
freedom that's why it's called the
liberal arts
but you're not getting that you should
at the very least get that and you're
not
you're not getting that at all so break
it up break it up what's the point
more and more employers i'm seeing don't
care
if you have a certain special college
degree
more and more i know because those
college degrees are increasingly not
reflecting
the the skill set that they were
supposed to reflect
so so that is falling apart this is an
opportunity to to break that down you
know it's it's
it's very difficult to break away from
an old system
but that is what's happening there's an
old system crumbling around us we need
to have courage we need to have
perseverance even if it looks like the
empire strikes back we need to
fight back against this we need new
maybe self-directed educational
opportunities such as the ones
with my friends at thinker.org you know
thinkor.org if you watch my book show at
prageru
you've heard of thinker thinker
summarizes the key ideas from new and
noteworthy nonfiction
giving you access to an entire library
of great books in bite size form
these are best-selling books think of
dale carnegie's how to win friends and
influence people
jordan peterson's best-selling 12 rules
for life they will summarize
them they'll give you the key bits of
information thinker offers a large
variety of titles for many categories
current affairs
politics business education history
relationships
you will even find ben shapiro's right
side of history
and matt walsh's the unholy trinity but
it doesn't stop there hopefully they'll
have my book on there too the one with
words when it comes out
if you want to challenge your
preconceptions if you want to expand
your horizons if you want to sound smart
at cocktail parties most important of
all
go to thinkor t-h-i-n-k-r
dot org start a free trial and download
the app today let them know that you
heard about them
on the michael nola show that is thinker
t-h-i-n-k-r
no e no time for that dot org
uh we have got a lot more to get to here
there have been fears of a great
reset uh with the lockdowns with the way
that the establishment is trying to
build back better and all these kind of
creepy slogans
uh well we're starting to see that come
to fruition with the notion of
vaccine passports that is no longer
just a tinfoil hat fear that is no
longer the stuff of dystopian
science fiction novels that would appear
to be implemented now in parts of the
united kingdom
uh head on over to dailywire.com right
now
if you haven't ordered them yet you have
to go order them the daily wire
christmas ornaments the these were made
by a long time viewer
of the daily wire and all access member
and friend of ours
they look great they are all of the
daily wire hosts
plus little tiny jasper as elves they
are
really well printed they're on a nice
metal ornament
you need to have us hanging on your tree
text christmas to eight three four zero
zero
that is at christmas to 83
400 to get your tree decorated they are
going very very fast
get yours now we'll be right back with a
lot more
we're back let's reset and let's get
ready for
the great reset that our elites are
trying to foist upon us
this term reset is is not just the stuff
of fevered conspiracy theories
you you have heard leaders around the
world use this phrase with regard to the
lockdown
it did occur to me early on in the
lockdown that
as as the rules were always changing and
the justification was always changing we
needed to lock down to
to slow the spread or flatten the curve
then we did flatten the curve and they
said no we need to find a cure
and we do have a cure i guess with these
vaccines 95 effective but we're still
locking down again
it just seemed like the justification
was always changing it occurred to me
the coronavirus lockdowns basically gave
the left the green new deal
isn't that strange cut down emissions by
a whole lot
gave the government much more control
than it had
set up massive spending schemes massive
redistribution
of wealth all in the name of this global
threat
that we're all going to die from even
though it has a very very very
very high survival rate we're all going
to die
unless you give us a lot of power un
unprecedented power from the perspective
of the united states
and a lot a lot of money this is the
same argument for the green new deal the
world is going to end if you don't give
us all the power and all the money
and when's it going to end i don't know
it's going to end in what she said she
said 12 years
aoc but that was a couple years ago so
now it's 10 years i guess
i i promise you the world is not going
to end in 10 years i think it's very
unlikely uh
if it is i'll you know i'll only each
100 bucks or something prince charles
who's
hysteric when it comes to the
global warming alarmism he said a number
of years ago that the world was going to
end in 18 months
and still here as far as as far as we
can tell
but it's the same argument it's
fundamentally the same argument and now
these fears are becoming even
more real for this so-called reset uh
wales in the united kingdom
is implementing something akin to a
vaccine passport
from the welsh health minister von
gitting he says those receiving a
covid19 vaccination
will be given a credit card sized
national health service wales
immunization card which will have the
vaccine name
date of immunization and batch number of
each of the doses given
hand written on them
huh what why am i getting an
identification card
to tell me that i've had this vaccine
that has just come out it's not even
available to the public yet
what would i need that for now of course
the health minister here says oh it's
free it's just for your own good it's
just to remind you
he says these these cards will act as a
reminder for the second dose and for the
type of vaccine
it will also give information about how
to report side effects okay well i don't
need to carry a card around have a phone
number i can just put that on my phone
uh this comes amid concerns though that
uh british businesses not even just the
government businesses
will start to require proof of
vaccination
as a condition of entering their
businesses
this has been suggested a lot before now
you're going to see a lot of arguments
crop back here because
notice that it won't be the government
leading the mandates for the
vaccine passport it will be businesses
and there will be some
maybe more libertarian-minded
conservatives who will say oh well
it's just business you get businesses
are free to do whatever they want as
long as it's not the government
forcing me to take this vaccine and
carry around proof of it all the time as
long as it's not the government it's
totally fine
and you will have conservatives saying
no i don't think so
i don't care if my life is being upended
and my civil rights taken away
and my uh traditions destroyed and my
society wrecked and my family broken up
i don't care if it's
the government doing that or big
business doing that or anyone else doing
that i don't want that to happen
i don't want to if if i am prevented
from engaging in our society
without this vaccine or a proof of the
vaccine by business
or the government the end result is the
same
and i don't really care the mechanism i
don't really care about the procedure
i don't want that to happen i do not
deny i think i think conservatives
actually go a little bit wrong
when they deny that the government has
the right to make you do extraordinary
things
in the name of emergencies that's what
the police power is for that's how we
had this whole lockdown fostered on us
in the first place because the
government
does have the legitimate police power
the government has the right to force
you to take a vaccine
for goodness sakes it seems extreme but
there have been court cases to this
effect
so i think we need to stop arguing from
this abstract perspective
and just say it's rights they have no
right to do this the government's bad
business is good whatever this
abstraction is and get down into the
particulars
i know that that you know that involves
more apprehension it involves more
uncertainty okay that's where battles
are fought and won
that's where life is lived the
government has the right to
certain police powers yeah totally grant
that government even has the right to
force someone to be vaccinated during an
epidemic okay sure
fine i'm not even gonna fight that i
don't want this
i don't want the government to force
everybody to take this vaccine
i don't want big business to force
everybody to take this vaccine
i don't want to be required to carry a
vaccine passport
i'm not making an abstract argument
about that i'm making a narrow political
argument
i as far as i can tell we the people
still have some voice in our government
that hasn't totally been taken away
john ossoff who's running for the senate
in georgia espouse the view of the
democrats if they get power which is we
need to take more power away from we the
people
need to give it over to experts who
knows so much better than we know
ourselves
uh-uh not yet i'm not willing to concede
that yet we still have a right
to express the way that we want to live
in our politics in our society
and i don't want that i think we need to
push back against that you are starting
to see this by the way
you're seeing business owners push back
against this you're seeing people go out
in the streets
and show up to bars show up to
restaurants
and they're not it's not like blm
they're not going in and you know
peacefully stealing gucci handbags and
nike sneakers
they're going and they want to keep
their businesses open and they want to
frequent their favorite businesses and
they want to see their family and they
want to see
their friends the great reset such as it
is
will in not come out
overnight as some total dystopian
overturning of society
it will be a gradual process like the
frog and the boiling water the
temperature goes up and up and up and
you don't realize
how much danger you're in until it's
boiling the great reset whatever that
means is going to be a reframing of the
country
the country right now is broadly
considered a center-right country
and has been for some time it seems less
and less true each day
as we radically redefine reality
marriage
uh sexuality itself as we redefine the
family as we redefine our relationship
to the government and it's it's
seeming less and less that way all the
time
but if we were a center right country
the way that we're going to reframe it
is
we're going to continue to say we're a
center-right country but the politics is
going to move far to the left
jennifer rubin one of the most dishonest
columnists in america jennifer rubin at
the washington post
who pretends to be a conservative she's
a far left radical liberal and she
actually
calls herself a conservative jennifer
rubin says
that the the country is center-right
and the biden administration if it and
ascends to the presidency will be center
right
headline of her piece joe biden's
personnel picks
engender no legitimate gop gripes
she writes i kid you not president-elect
joe biden
has selected a flock of experienced
center-right
nominees for top positions progressive
enough to reassure
most democrats and reasonable enough to
impress conservative
policy wonks when it looks more certain
how this presidential race will play out
you know it's
it is getting more certain by the day
unfortunately
we can go through all of the biden picks
he hasn't named
too many yet i think because he doesn't
want to spook people
i think he he wants it uh he wants to
just put out a few
pics and then wait and see when it looks
like he's gonna win this
the court cases for sure it looks like
he's gonna win the electoral college for
sure
then i think he'll come out and be
honest about how radical these guys are
but already you see pictures with some
of his personal picks
wearing hammer and sickle hats i kid you
not
wearing a hammer and sickle or some of
his picks now
for instance is pick for the office
management budget radical left
very very far left these are not
center-right people
but they they could be center-right if
if you take the framing from
say barack obama on the left to
donald trump on the right then
these joe biden picks are radical left
but if you take the framing from let's
say donald trump on the right and uh
karl marx on the left or aoc
or lenin i don't know che guevara on the
left
then all of a sudden the picks do seem
center right because you've moved
the extremes you've you've moved excuse
me
you've moved the edges so so far
that now the biden picks seem legitimate
you're seeing this on wikipedia actually
too so there was an article on wikipedia
put up by one of their editors called
re-writing wikipedia
this went up by one of their
pseudonymous editors newsslinger
talking about how wikipedia is
anti-conservative we all know this if
you
if you ever looked at most conservatives
i would say at this point who are given
a wikipedia page
they're called conspiracy theorists
they're called spreaders of fake news
they always they attack my page they
attack
daily wires page they attack everett
charlie kirk whoever all these guys
and so people have been complaining
about this and we've said wikipedia is a
left-wing news source
well wikipedia comes out and they said
no actually wikipedia is center-right
because of some study from a harvard
center the berkman client center report
identified wikipedia
as a center-right website on the
candidate valence scale
throughout the 2016 u.s elections and
i'm sure
that there are going to be other
arguments that you hear oh yes according
to politifact
wikipedia is center right oh yes
according to aoc wikipedia center right
okay it's not center right
according to me that's going to be a
reframing and
it doesn't feel quite as satisfying to
just gradually try to pull the country
back to the right
but that is what conservatives do we are
not
radicals we are not even revolutionaries
we are conservatives we want
gradual change because gradual change
will be lasting change
and that's where life exists
the left did not just win an election
and thereby take the culture
the left embarked on a decades-long
march through the institutions took over
higher education
took over the media took over hollywood
took over technology the big tech
as we know it today is really on what
about 30 years old they took it over
complete completely
all of these institutions they went in
they worked they did this grunt work we
don't know many of the names of these
radicals who took it over
because they just were nobody right they
were just functionaries of the left-wing
cause and all of a sudden you wake up in
the country's much
much further to the left well we have to
do a similar sort of thing
occasionally occasionally we can push
back on these guys
and it's it's not always going to be
successful sometimes it is though
candice owens just got this actually
candace owens made the perfectly
accurate statement
the other day on facebook that joe biden
is not
the president-elect i've made this
statement too
people excoriate me for it is simply a
fact that joe biden is not
the president-elect well she was
censored
she was called a liar by politifact
politifact the objective
neutral probably center-right
fact-checking right now it's left-wing
why did they call her a liar i don't
know because they said
the media called the race and oh it
looks like he's going to get all these
votes
candace did not just roll over candace
lawyered up
threatened to sue them and politifact
offered a rare correction
she offered this correct they offered
this question they said whoopsie daisy
we've gone back and looked and said oh
yes we've now corrected this okay
well this is important because these
fact-checking websites quote unquote
left-wing websites like like politifact
are involved
in determining what gets censored on
social media platforms
so social media platforms pretend that
they've got these
neutral fact checkers who are you know
and they throw their hands up in the air
but no they partner with these left-wing
organizations and so we've got to push
back
and you know what if you push back
against them you are going to fail
not just nine out of 10 times you're
probably going to fail 99 out of 100
times
but if you just keep it up eventually
eventually you might succeed you can
also vote with your feet right
right now we've learned that
hewlett-packard is leaving california
they announced this on tuesday
hewlett-packard is
currently located in san jose california
they are going to move to texas
why because texas imposes a 0.75
franchise tax on business margins
california imposes an 8.85
corporate tax 8.85 percent not to
mention that texas has no individual
income tax compared to california's
current top rate
of 13.3 percent which is now expected to
rise to 16.3 percent very soon
it's a state tax you know we moved to to
tennessee right now i'm in washington dc
because we shot some episodes of verdict
with
senator ted cruz but when i go back to
tennessee i will not be paying any state
uh income taxes very
important stuff because there are a lot
of people fleeing california now i mean
the state's tennessee
texas they're filling up because you can
vote with your feet now is that going to
change the culture overnight no
but there are these modest gains that
you can make and if you just
show that you're not going to back down
that will have a far greater effect
maybe than you
expect if you look these crooks in the
eye and you say
i think i won this election i think that
the system for a number of reasons
was made vulnerable to fraud and not
just that but it was illegitimate and in
some cases in pennsylvania was
unconstitutional the way it was set up
and i think that we need to challenge
this election in the courts
and you keep that up and you look and
they say no we're going to take it from
you we know where biden's going to win
no according to the system and you look
and you say
okay i'm going to keep fighting you but
you know what if you beat me on this bet
i'll see you again in four years
i'm not giving up do not give up no
matter how daunting the odds i'm michael
knowles
this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clinton